مبروك مبروك قديمه
[موسيقى]
شيرين ابو عقله شيرين كيف تبدو طبيعه
الموقف الان
شيرين
بطبيعه الحال عن باب الاسباط نعم لا يسمح
للفلسطينيين طبعا بالدخول اوكي اوكي
تكون معنويه واحيانا كمان جسديه
كيف تحافظ على امنك شيرين ابو عقله
الجزيره قرب حاجزي بيته شمال رام الله
في الحادي عشر من مايو 2022 قتلت الصحفيه
الفلسطينيه
انا لما شفتها في هذا الفيلم سنتحدث الى
شهود ذلك اليوم وكذلك الى عائله شيرين
ابو عقله
[موسيقى]
مش مستعد يعني يستسهل انه يدوس
الاسرائيليين فاتوا تقريبا خمسه ونصف
اجاني هذا الفيديو مش تصويري
الحادي عشر من مايو بدا مبكرا يعني
على الموقع
في ذلك الوقت كانت القوات الاسرائيليه
المحتله تقود الكثير من الاقتحامات
العسكريه في مدينه جنين
[موسيقى]
قبل 11/05 كان الحديث عن انه في عمليه
اسرائيليه واشتياح
عمل عليك صحفي في جنين لاكثر من 30 عاما
وكثيرا عندما كانت تتوجه لتغطيه المنطقه
باي وقت اتصل مفتوح التلفون دي ما كانتش
تسكر التليفون
[موسيقى]
صنع دوار العوده الي هو المدخل الغربي
للمخيم ال ما كان في شيء كانت هدوء تام
[موسيقى]
رين من ضمنهم شذى حمايشه ومجاهد السعدي
ما في اشتباكات ما في مظاهر في ما في
مظاهر للمقاومين
البست الواطي انا وشيرين كان في شباب
موجودين متواجدين صار يقول لها الجيش فوق
الجيش في المخيم فوق
[موسيقى]
وجود الصحفي
سليم عوض
بدا يصور فيديو
صباحا على التيك توك
بعد دقائق
الاسرائيليه في الشارع
الجيش
[موسيقى]
يضحكون
ولبستنا شيرين الطاقيه وطولك مرتي ولبست
الطاقيه تبعتي ولحقتها
[موسيقى]
كلنا لابسين اللباس السلام المهنيه الواقي
الخوذه
عشان هم يشوفون جيدا وشخصونك يا صحفيين
وصلنا نمشي بطريقه
[موسيقى]
هم يسرون
بعد تخطي المكان الذي كان يدل منه سليم
على الجيش
فجاه طلعت رصاصه فانا صيحت شيرين بطخوا
علينا لازم نرجع من هون بعدني بقول لازم
نرجع من هون
على سور قصير لاحتمي فيه شيرين
كانت اخر كلمه قالتها شيرين على تصاوب على
التصاوب يعني انا دينيه هدول كل يوم طول
الوقت بيردد بداني صوت شيرين
شرير شرير يا عم شريف
انا حامل الكاميرا بدي امشي امشي روحي
باتجاه شيرين
[موسيقى]
بتذكر لما طلعت على الارض وشفت الدم لما
بلش الدم ينزل
ووقع ان استوعبت انه رصاصه براسها وبلاش
تصرخ انه براسها براسها
[موسيقى]
فحاولت اول مره
شريف فوق الجدار في محاوله للمساعده
لكنهم اطلق النار
[موسيقى]
قدر انه بالرغم من كثافه اطلاق الرصاص
قدر انه ينقذ شذى ويخليها تقفز خلف الصور
كنت انا وياها الراقب شو اللي راح يحصل مع
شريف خلال سحب ولا شيرين
كانت
حراره الدم او
دقات القلب الاخير
انا كنت في المستشفى وقاعدين بعزوا فيه
وخلاص يعني انا
عندي قناعه انه انا هاي لحظات الاخيره
في الدنيا سمعت صوت اسعاف جاي
انا بسالهم مين الي تصاوب خير يا رب
[موسيقى]
هاي رصاصه ثانيه
اول ما اعطوهم كانوا يكونوا جميعا بس لا
كانت شيء
[موسيقى]
كانت انسان رائعه
صحفيه لبنانيه ملتزمه كانت انسانه كريمه
كانت مدرسه
هي اجت عشان تقتل الاحداث
ليش يقتلوها
[موسيقى]
بتذكر كل كل
اطلاق رصاص صوتها لسه براسي
يلا تاخرنا يعني هي صوتها لسه ما لحقت
وتبعد عنا
هذا الكابوس
كل يوم
كل يوم معيشه كل يوم اسمع صوتك
انا مش ممكن ننساه
[موسيقى]
عندما جاء بها لنا من جنين كان دائما في
حقيبتها
قبل 30 سنوات
احدث
صور ارسلت رساله لها وقلت شيرين
هذا الخبر العاجل هل انت بخير من فضلك
وحاول الاتصال
[موسيقى]
بعد يومين من مقتل شيرين اقيمت جنازه لها
في القدس المحتله
خرج الالف الى الشوارع حدادا على فقدها
وكذلك اعترافا بما تعنيه للفلسطينيين
[تصفيق]
لكن حاله الحزن
لحظه خروج
من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضرب المشجعين
وحامد النعش واستخدم الهراوات واستخدم
الغاز المسيده للدموع واستخدم القنابل
بالصوت
[موسيقى]
ها مره اخرى
من الفلسطينيين
الشيعي
وهذا معرفه
[موسيقى]
هذه في مكتبها في رام الله
في بعض الاحيان كانت تقدم تقريرها من
المنزل عبر الهاتف وتذكره انها كانت تبدا
دائما بالعبد التنازلي
4-321 ثم تبدا هذه هي مع الراحل ياسر
عرفات
واذهب الى الغرفه كانت لدينا طاوله ليجو
حمراء
ومعي هاتف باربي
وحاولوا اسرائيل واسكات الاحتجاجات ضدها
لكنها لم تفلح حتى الان الا في زياده
الاحتقان والتوتر مع الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
بعد الاعلان عن مقترها في وقت قصير اصدر
الجيش الاسرائيلي بيانا قال فيه ان
الفلسطينيين ربما كان هم المسؤولين عن ذلك
الحكومه الاسرائيليه هذا الفيديو قائله ان
مسلحا فلسطينيا على الارجح ومن اطلق النار
على شيرين لكن منظمه بيت سالم الحقوقيه
الاسرائيليه فضحت سيف للدعاء حيث ارسلت
باحثا الى الموقع الذي ظهر في الفيديو
وكشفت انه محال ان تكون قد قتلت من هناك
نحن ايضا ذهبنا الى الموقع
الذي قتلت فيه علينا
لا يوجد خط رؤيه واضح لماذا الجيش
الاسرائيلي سيخرج شيئا كهذا يصلون
مهتمين
ايضا على الافلات من العقاب
القانونيه وفي كثير من الاحيان يستخدمه
بشكل مباشر لذا في ما يتعلق بمحاوله
التحكم في الروايه يمكنك ان ترى كيف تغيرت
هوايتهم من ربما كان فلسطينيا
من هنا يمكنك ان ترى انها في الحائط ولا
يمكن ان تصل الى شيرين سنتجه يا ساره
[موسيقى]
وهناك مدرسه امامنا مباشره
التي لم تحظى بالاهتمام الدولي ولم تكن
لها لقطات فيديو ولم يكن هناك فقط
هذا هو المكان الذي كانت فيه الدوريه
الاسرائيليه
في الاسابيع التي ثلاث مقتلها قال تحقيق
تلو الاخر من وسائل الاعلام الى منظمات
حقوق الانسان الى الامم المتحده ان جنديا
اسرائيليا على الارجاح قتل 20
في سبتمبر قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه من
المرجح ان يكون احد جنوده قد قتلها لكنه
ادعى انها علقت في تبادل الاطلاق النار
فلما سمعنا صوت الرصاصه
وقفنا مين اللي كان قدامنا بس الدوريات
مستحيل المسلحين كانوا معيدين جوا جوا
مستحيل رصاصتهم كليب
في الدقائق التي سبقت اطلاق النار اظهر ان
المكان كان هادئا ولم يكن هناك تبادل
لاطلاق النار او مسلحون فلسطينيون على
مقلوبه من الصحفيين ما يثير التساؤل حول
ما اذا كان بامكان الجنود الاسرائيليين
الرؤيه من كانوا يطلقون النار عليه في
محاوله للاجابه قامت مجموعه البحث بناء
الادله الجنائيه ومنظمه حقوق الانسان الحق
باعاده محاكاه واقعه القتل
التصوير الجويه الى نموذج ثلاثي الابعاد
تحدثنا مع احد باحث مؤسسه الحق وطلب وعدم
الكشف عن هويته بسبب ضغوط ومضايقات
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بدانا من حيث كانت
الدوريه في ذلك اليوم بالضبط
[موسيقى]
لموقع دوريه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
ما يتعلق بمكان وجود الصحفيين والمكان
الذي كانت تقف فيه شيرين بالضبط حين
اصابتها بعد التحقيق في نوع المنظار الذي
استخدمه الاسرائيليون على بندقيه ام فور
استخدمنا عدسه تصوير قياسا 200 ملي متر
لمحاكاه ما كان يمكن ان يراه الرامي كان
من الواضح ان الستره الصحفيه يمكن التعرف
عليها
[موسيقى]
كانت المسافه بين دوريه الاسرائيليه
والصحفيين حوالين 200 متر
القناص مصمما على انه كلما ظهر شخص في
مجال رؤيته اي يستهدفه على الفور لذلك
بمجرد ان يدخل في خط رؤيته نراه يستهدف
اولئك الاشخاص وبمجرد ان يهتموا خلف
الشجره خارج مجال رؤيته يتوقع
[موسيقى]
الرصاصات انها على مستوى راسي
جميع الطلقات التي اطلقت على مقربه من
بعضها البعض لذا كان الرامي مصمما ومتعمدا
استهداف الصحفيين في تلك الحادثه
رفض الجيش الاسرائيلي طلبنا اجراء مقابله
ولم يجب على الاسئله المكتوبه ايضا وبدلا
من ذلك حالنا الى تقرير النهائي عن القتل
لكن هناك طريق اخر للمساءله
كانت شيرين مواطنه امريكيه ومنذ البدايه
طلبت عائلتها من الحكومه الامريكيه اجراء
تحقيق مستقل
في يونيو كان هناك بصيص وامل
[موسيقى]
لكن بحلول يوليو عندما زار الرئيس المنطقه
لم يكن يبدو ان الاداره تريد معرفه
الحقائق
خلصت الولايات المتحده الى ان شيرين قتلت
على الارجاح بنيران الاسرائيليه لكن ذلك
لم يكن متعمدا الا انهم لم يحددوا كيف
توصلوا الى ذلك ولم يجدوا تحقيقا
وبدلا من ذلك لخص المسؤول عن التقرير وهو
المنسق الامني الامريكي نتائج التحقيقات
الفلسطينيه والاسرائيليه وبمجرد ان اصدرت
اسرائيل تقديرها النهائي بدا ان الولايات
المتحده تتراجع والمتابعه الاجراءات في
القضيه
ما حدا حكى بعيني
الاحتلال من جيش الاحتلال من طرف
الاسرائيلي لم احد يقوم
باستجوابي لا الامريكان ولا الاحتلال
كما لم ينشر الجيش الاسرائيلي لقطات
للجندي الذي اطلق النار على صحفيين او اي
نصوصا للمقابلات التي اجراها
من الموارد لكن لماذا يقومون بكل هذه
التحركات هذا امر المقصود
القانونيه
هي قبه
الجنود الاسرائيليين من العواقب القانونيه
الدوليه
سد الطريق امام الولايات القضائيه الدوليه
عامه
للولايات المتحده تعتمد بشكل كبير على
تحقيق الاسرائيلي في عمليه القتل هل تعتقد
ان هذا كافر
بل هو امر شائء لكن
مئات من ملفات القضايا الاخرى الحقيقه
الثابته هي ان اسرائيل لا تجري تحقيقات
تهدف الى محاسبه الناس
[موسيقى]
تحقيق الاسرائيلي مزعجا خاصه
في فلسطين او واشنطن
الامريكيه لكننا لم نحصل على اي شيء لم
يصدر منهم سوى الكلام
حريه الصحافه وحمايه صحفيين لكن عدم
تطبيقه لهذه القيم عندما قتلت شيرين كان
امرا مزعجاجا
وقد ظهرت زواجيه المعايير هذه عندما قتلت
صحفيه امريكيه فلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
في مقتل شيرين
ولم يعلن تحليله
امريكيه في البدايه لكن يبدو انهم تراجعوا
لكني اعتقد ويعتقد العديد من زملائي ان
علينا ان نصل الى حقيقه هذا الامر ولا يجب
كنزه تحت السجاده
رفضه وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه اتاحت
الوزير للتحدث معنا وفي مقابله احالنا
المتحدث باسم الوزاره باستمرار لتقرير
المنسق الامني الامريكي والتحقيق
الاسرائيليين والاسرائيليين وفي بعض
الحالات كان يسد الفجوه بين هذين تحقيقين
لاعداد النتائج الخاصه
قبيله اثناء اطلاق النار
عندما تكون هناك مزاعم بان مدنيه قد
استهدف عن عمه ما وجده الاسرائيليون
وموجده منسقنا الامني هو انا الامر لا
يبدو متعمدا لم يجد منسقنا الامني اي سبب
للاعتقاد بان شيرين ابو عقل قد استهدفت
عمدا من قبل الاسرائيليين
الرئيس السوري
وزير الخارجيه قال انه سيكون هناك تحقيق
مستقل لم يجرا لتحقيق المستقل هذا التراجع
سيرسل رساله خاطئه لكل انسان
وزاره الخارجيه اردنا ان نسال البيت
الابيض عن شيرين
حول مقتل صحفيه الجزيره شيرين ابو عاقله
لم يكن تقرير منافق الامني الامريكي
تحقيقا بل استند الى التحقيق الاسرائيلي
وتحقيق السلطه الفلسطينيه كان هناك تحميل
ولم تجر مقابلات مع اي من شهود الايام
الرئيسيين فلماذا لم تنزل الولايات
المتحده تحقيقا مستقلا في مقتل مواطنه
الامريكيه
بشكل كامل وشفاف ولدينا قناعه ان
الاسرائيليين شامل
[موسيقى]
بعد اسبوعين فقط من هذا الحديث وبعد اكثر
من سته اشهر من مقتل شيرين انتشرت الاخبار
بان مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي وبشكل
المستقل عن البيت الابيض سيفتح تحقيقا في
واقعه القتل الحكومه الاسرائيليه اوضحت
انها لم تتعاون بالنظر الى ذلك الى
تصريحات الامريكيه منذ واقعه القتل من غير
الواضح مدى دقه وشفافيه التحقيق حقا
[موسيقى]
انه يمكن ان يكون مفيدا اذا كان حقيقيا
لكني اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده فقدت
الكثيره من المصداقيه حتى الان في هذا
الصدد نحن لسنا في موقف محال الوقت
يعني احيانا كمان الجيش مش معني انك انت
تكوني موجوده فهو بيستهدفك انه يعني حتى
لو قال بالغلط ممكن يقول انه انا شفت انه
في شباب حواليكم بتعمق انه يستهدف هيك
كنوع من التخويف لانه هو كمان مش معناه
انك انت تكوني موجوده
قوات الاسرائيليه تداهم المباني وتبحث عن
المسلحين وتعتقل مئات المدنيين وتفجر
وتذهب وتخرب ممتلكات فلسطينيين ومساكنهم
فلسطين المحتله عبد الرحمن ابن العشره
اعوام
ايضا يلهو مع اصدقائه قرب بيتها حين وجه
جندي اسرائيلي رصاصه مباشره اليهم
ايش بتحب حسون
القاهره القاهره
مواقع سكس
داخل المخيم وورد التقرير عن وقوعه اصابات
او زملائها بالابلاغ عن هذا انهم يوثقون
ذلك واذا لم يحاسب
احدكم
ليس بالامر الجديد على قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ففي السادس من ابريل من عام
2018 استشهد الصحفي والمصور الفلسطيني
قرب الحدود مع خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه
كان ياسر حريص على توفيق احداث الجمعه
الثانيه لمسيره العوده السلميه لكن
الرصاصه الاسرائيليه المتفجره اجلته قبل
ان يكمل مهمته
اصبح ياسر اول صحفيين يستشهد في مسيرات
العوده التي انطلقت في قطاع غزه نهايه شهر
مارس 2018
للمطالبه بانهاء الحصار الاسرائيلي وحق
عوده اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
[تصفيق]
حاله استهدافا للصحفيين باستخدام الغاز
الموسيقي
العوده
ضد الصحفيين الفلسطينيين الذين يغطون
مسيرات العوده وفي عموم الوطن في كل مكان
في الوطن كان هناك قرار باستهدافه منهج
لكل الصحفيين الفلسطينيين
لم يغفل احتلال يوما عدائه لاقلام
الصحفيين وكاميراتهم ولم تعد الدروع
المطبوع عليها كلمه الصحافه او الخوذه
التي يضعها الصحفي فوق راسه تحميانه من
الاستهداف بلند دعوات الملاحقه والتحرير
ضد الصحفيين بات تطلق على نيه كما جاء في
تصريح عضو الكنيسه اليمني المتطرف اثمار
من غفير
من اعلى المستويات اي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وبتنفيذ من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد
الصحفي الفلسطيني نحن نتعرض لحرب شامله
حقيقيه من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ونلاحظ
حسب احصائيات لجنه الحريات في نقابه
الصحفيين الفلسطينيين ان اكثر الاستهداف
هو في مدينه القدس تليها مدينه جنين في
الضفه الغربيه
من قبل الجيش باي حال من الاحوال لان
عملهم هو الاعلام ونقل شهادتهم بشان
النزاع وما يحدث على الارض
وسائل الاعلام
وسلوك تقليدي للقوات المسلحه الاسرائيليه
وهذا امر تستنكره
مراسلنا بلا حدود
68 على و 63 الصادر عام 2013 ينص على عدم
جواز افلات مرتكب الجرائم بحق الصحفيين من
العقاب غير ان اليه تنفيذه لم ترى النور
حتى الان
هو الاتحاد الدولي سنقدم مشروع قرار
للتصويت عليه في الامم المتحده وانا اريد
من كل صراع العالم ان يصوتوا هذا القرار
لنحمي كل صحفي العالم
الدوليه وقررات النظر في بعض عمليات القتل
المرتكبه بحق الصحفيين
ان الامر سيستغرق وقت طويلا في حاله شيرين
صحفيين لانه انا هذا السؤال بيقرقني من
وقت الحدث انه ليش ليش استهدفونا يعني بس
في شعور جواتي عارف لان هم ما بدهم ما
بدهم الحقيقه وحقيقه ايش بيصير على ارض
الواقع في مخيم جنين وفي الضفه وفي فلسطين
يكون ظاهر والناس تعرفه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
225 فلسطينيه
اكثر دمويه هنا منذ عام 2005
خلال الاقتحام العسكريا عندما كنا في جنين
قتل فلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
هدف اطلاق النار
اخافه كل الصحافه الفلسطينيه في واحده
كبيره في راس كبير
صعب بالنسبه لي اكبر موجوده بالميدان لانه
كل صوت رصاصه هو بيذكرني باللي صار بحسسي
يعني صرت احس حالي كثير مستهدفه
بالفترات اللي غطيت فيها بعد الحدث كنت
حتى الرصاص اللي بعيد
بعد مقتل شيرين قررت شذى اخذ استراحه من
العمل كصحفيه في فلسطين للدراسه في بيروت
ونموذج
الحديث اللي صار حسيت فيه اشي جواته انكسر
فحسيت انه انا لازم شوي اكون اقوي
اكون احسن
الشعب الفلسطيني مين اللي بده ينقل الامنا
وفرحنا للعالم
قبل ساعات من احتفال المسلمين في انحاء
المعموره بعيد الاضحى المبارك
تعيش القدس يوم حزن اخر يسيطر فيه
الاحتلال على المسجد الاقصى يحدد من
يدخلوا الى داخل المسجد الاقصى ومن يصلي
فيه ومتى
عقيل علينا فراق الزميله شيرين ابو عقلي
ولكن هناك ضرورات
لا احنا نكمل
الجزيره اريحا شيرين
شيرين
عند اهل المخيم عند الشعب الفلسطيني
عند الكل شيرين لها حضور
[موسيقى]
محتله